you remember your first acting job I do
I so I lived in DC I would drive up to
Baltimore to audition for things in my
first my first job I ever got was the
show called the corner was on HBO I was
like Charles has done this in the 90s
it's all and was for this part called
white boy I had two lines white boy
white boys named the character a
character who had been playing all your
lives
got this so really it was just called
white boy white boy had to die and so I
drove up I auditioned I drove back two
days later and manager called was like
they want you I was so happy
a couple weeks later drive up to
Baltimore I get to set and I like find
the you know lady in charge of base camp
I'm like I'm white boy she's like
fantastic takes me my trailer says white
boy I go in I put on my white boy
wardrobe
I learned my - white boy lines they take
me to hair and makeup I go through the
works you know I'm I'm really nervous
somebody comes and wires me up for sound
and I'm just I'm just like so in the
zone I'm ready to do it and suddenly the
door to my trailer opens and there's
this guy who's like my age and looks
kind of like me and he's like what are
you doing
like what closed the door and he's like
I'm white boy I was like I'm white boy
he's like I am I am white but we got
into a thing we go storming off and you
know side by side nothing worse than two
angry white boys
alright I'm like we are gonna get to the
bottom of this you know finding the the
lady who signed us up were like who who
is white boy tell us now and she's like
who's Eric um clearly the other guy was
white but my manager had called said
they want you she didn't say
as an extra so I so you were wrong I was
wrong I wasn't white boy this guy was
white but I've gone in his clothes I
thought their hair and makeup I've been
what I had to take all this stuff off
that's humiliating it was humiliating
and then that everyone's mad at me I
made the whole production late because
now there's this like fiasco and I and
and I had to sit there on set as a next
row up just feeling misery was like
welcome to show but also it's like if
you're gonna steal a part you wouldn't
steal the to line part of white boy
is still you could have you gonna come
in and said yes I'm the lead on the
corner yeah and then you know at least
me Charles Dutton exactly I don't think
so
you